kommt doch noch ein level oder nein
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zurück zu einer weiteren
folge genf zusammen mit kommen die
letzte folge kam bei komme ich bin auch
ich bin immer noch ein game und mensch
verdammt da ich folge auch keine
berechtigung komme oh mensch hatte op
contractor jetzt auch ich brauche nicht
mal whitelist irgendwie hat der grieche
komplett runtergeschmissen nach der
letzten folge
ich war immer schon gesagt zur letzten
folge der gommer hat die letzte folge
alleine aufgenommen das tut mir leid
aber ich war bei einem kumpel und wir
haben gelernt alles möglich das war da
ein bisschen verdammt da war noch viel
schwieriger war ein bisschen lob für
mich da irgendwie zeit zu finden das
links das ich letzte folge nicht dabei
war auch uhrmann verdacht gibt sie
einfach selbst runter insgesamt warten
und wir haben uns gesagt wir da ihr das
ja nicht so toll fanden dass wir da
immer zu dem nächsten ding hinfliegen
gehen wir einfach bleiben wir mal in
einem ganz normalen gamer 0 und
versuchen das ganze dann einfach auf die
legale art und weise zu schaffen mehr
als optik game holt auch illegal während
man also ja ich verstehe dass immer noch
nicht wie man an leitern so trans liegen
springen kann
normalerweise die sprünge hier die gehen
normalerweise alle ich war schon viel
weiter aber da kommen ja noch viel
heftigere sprünge mit leitern der
kommentator letzte folgerichtig für
geschafft also seht schon wir sind hier
an einer stelle an der wir noch gar
nicht waren also in meiner moa also an
in der in meiner folge waren wir immer
ganz woanders und da kommt es richtig
weit gekommen da muss ich sagen
herzlichen glückwunsch an gestört
eingestuft von können nicht mehr auch
viel kaufen jetzt du irgendwann
wir hatten ja irgendwann mal so wer
wettet dass ich irgendwie dir irgendwas
aus zu habe ich hab echt schon wieder
vergessen
das hatte ich aber sogar einem video
gesagt freuen wenn ihr das irgendwie
noch willst dann schreibt soll bitte das
werden wir so witzig was wieder gewettet
haben das ist aber auch schon länger her
obwohl wir glaube ich auch bei der karte
ja auch etwas gewendet hatten nicht weiß
es nicht jaja ich ja ja ich halte ich
habe gesagt ich hatte gesagt ich mach
irgendwie werden wir meinen ganzen tag
wenn ich das jetzt schaffe oder so aber
ich habe es nicht geschafft er ist aber
noch eine andere welt es gab noch andere
glaube ich in aller regel nicht weit
ich bin da ich bin also runter gegründet
er das immer wirst du es nie dabei am
besten also wenn du bist immer das
nicken immer schiff zu schiff ja aber
ich bin ich springe dann gegen die
leiter gegen quasi und es leidet dann so
runter da wieder runter weiß was ich
meine und das leise ist einfach shift
nein das tue ich beobachte dich jetzt
mal komm cook aber nein das heißt dass
alstom das war dem ok film macht immer
weiter ich hoffe ich glaube einfach an
dich aber ich hatte einen schuss und du
bist einfach drauf geblieben
die stabiler typ ich bin so stabil waren
mich kriegt hier immer wieder braucht
schon einen ganzen stack weile damit du
mich da irgendwie vom blog runter
bekommst du bist wieder drauf geblieben
und jetzt mache gerade test bei dir
stabil
krass ey com ich hab das jetzt geschafft
das jetzt ich hab' das ruhig etwas eine
leiter in der letzten folge sogar
relativ oft geschafft
ich hoffe wir schaffen dass dieser eine
doofe sprung
wenn wir aus dem raum heraus sind da
kommt noch viel heftigere sprünge und da
war ich schon
wir kommen ja nicht mal mehr da alle
gerade es läuft nein nein so lange an
der leitha verdammt da muss doch gut da
muss doch irgendwie taktik er shift
nutzlos ist
dann rutschte ich immer so runter weiß
ich hänge dann an der leiter quasi und
rückstand nach links und denkt man
sofort an fachlicher leiter runter
musste nach rechts lenken
falls du bist auf der leiter gebliebene
bischof stabiler typ bin stabil aber
durch kokosmilch dagegen gesprochen die
sich auf die leiter du musst mit doppelt
sprints an die leiter dahinter wenn ein
wenig abstand daran vorbei
sie ist wie eine wand das heißt ich muss
gar nicht auf die leiter drauf quasi
justieren wo ich gerade dran bin da
kommst auch in einer versammlung habe
ich weiß ich weiß wie das mainz okay gut
ich bin mir versucht seine reiter dazu
bleiben
na gut dann dann klappt das
wahrscheinlich dann ist man erst es doch
echt gemeint leider ein bisschen
beispiel noch an die härtere leiter
sprünge ehrlich warst du da oben schon
ja ich war schon viel weiter wirklich
ich wahrscheinlich aus dem rohr aus als
ob hallo ihr grün kräfte hast du da
nicht gewartet dann recht ein wunder
gefallen bin
aber das sieht gerade gut auskomme oro
und jetzt pass auf das ist der clou das
ist der den sprung du das sehr gut mit
der habe ich noch nie doch die habe ich
einmal geschafft glaube ich der muss
richtig spät abspringen
also richtig spricht auch richtig
angefangen zu schießen
naja du willst selber wieder an
jetzt tötete der folge heute einfach da
wollte ich nur angeln
ich wollte ich nur oh mein gott oh mein
gott oh gott weiß was geschafft habe ich
stehe auf der leiter darauf auf die ich
gar nicht drauf stellen wollte
aber ich bin jetzt auch da wo du warst
mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
yeah yeah komme ich bin auch bei dem
crazy sprung ja ich habe ich auch
geschafft um erhalt alter wie gut wie
gut sind will gerade alter alter wo ich
bin sicher ich seh dich ich bin über dir
gerade noch jetzt alles kann die
leitersprossen muss ich hin wo man sich
da
doch richtig mein gott was ist denn los
mit mir
die waren was ist los mit dir du kannst
du doch wieder drauf ja oh mein gott
komme wo sind wir mal was es dafür
sowieso gut muss sich vom regen muss
sich von hierhin ihr darauf wo ich die
frage gestellt habe man darf derzeit nur
nicht komplett wieder runter fallweise
muss denn hier nach hin
ja hier rauf kommt man drauf ja ich habe
es immer schon dreimal geschafft
nein nein ok und jetzt jetzt an die
leiter hier und dann darauf immer ein
stückchen höher es ist doch so schwierig
auch wir nicht auch verdammt ich hab das
gefühl weiß ich fange jeder komplett
runter ich hab das gefühl habe ich auch
aber irgendwie auch nicht euro will ich
denn hier schon wieder darüber wie hoch
sind wie die baskische auch schon soweit
der körper auf einmal wollen wir
schaffen es auf einmal weiter l
jetzt kommt der größte anspruch den ich
mal hier wirst du gegen die decke
springen und darüber kommen und ich
probiere ich boxen ein knappes ding
knopf ist dinge zu weit gesprungen komme
aber ich glaube an uns vor allem erst
mal sieben minuten wir schaffen das
mockup war das wäre so gern wenn wir das
jetzt schaffen wir sagen sie ja
vielleicht zwei drei folgen
vielleicht schafft ist jetzt sogar schon
kommt doch noch ein level oder nein
30 10 oder ich sehe nur so gekommen
darunter fallen das ist nicht mehr
gerecht was in diesem spiel in diesem
spiel vor sich geht es letztlich gerecht
das ist nicht mehr lustig nee leute wo
ich war ja noch fast total runter
gefallen walter die ersten zimmer das
ist ja nicht mehr normal hier bei mir
haag ist auch immer so ein bisschen ich
zähle mich jetzt darauf habe ich keinen
bock soweit kriegt mich keiner nicht
dass ich gleich nochmal tastatur an bord
holen
dann lieber einmal porten ist ja nicht
mehr normal erhalte halte die sprünge
hier die sind aber auch zum packen zum
kacken dann noch mal wenn du normal
runterfällt hast dich aber nicht normal
brunnen echt nicht werde ich dagegen bis
sogar wieder und ich nicht wieso jetzt
schaffe ich nicht mehr den sprung alter
ich rauche ich wie viel kohle hast du
ich hab 43 ja ich habe 19
das regt mich so oft dass ich da oben
weiter gelaufen bin eher danach wenn es
nur noch zwei sprünge gewesen bis zum
nächsten dings weise ich bin online auf
sky will mich jetzt wieder anrufen würde
wäre richtig doof hat mich ganz schön
sky probleme weil ich war irgendwie
meiner tonspur war ich komplett leise ja
ja ja ich hab s geschafft und jetzt
jetzt über die ihr alter las islas ist
nicht nur wegen der wm wie konntest du
dich zum importen nur weil ich hier oben
war obwohl manchmal etikett sie
verarscht uns kommen wo ich bin du musst
mich anfeuern dass die machen eine
ablehne
mein gott apfelernte lass mich mal
gucken
ich habe angst guckst du aber
schriftlich nicht okay
wegen nicht kommen lassen
ich bin wieder ganz unten
wir sind doch sowieso müll einfach nie
sein
wir waren beide schon da oben und wir
boxen einfach weitere die ganze show
wieder hier würde so viel schaffen
werden nicht so dumm war noch so wie vor
nicht das lasse ich lass den scheiß alle
ich sag's dir worden
du wirst sie tricks
das ist mal kommen wir müssen das jetzt
mal schaffen hier ein bisschen wir
weiterkommen weil es ist so kacke also
leiter springen hier
ich gehe die ganze zeit wieder zurück
einfach ich habe angst dass ich runter
fallen die ganze zeit wieder zurück oh
mein gott wir sind genau gleich schnell
wieder runter
ich bin oben also ich war nur 100 du
bist so ein goldketten oh mein gott oh
mein gott betten
ich habe ich liege im bett bin ich froh
wir haben relativ gut geschafft eltern
sagen sagt ich gedacht dass wir es
schaffen ich das nochmal schaffen wir
haben es auch mit porten geschafft aber
das war jetzt nur sonne weil wir machen
das man nicht habe mir vorher gesagt
mit game mode werden nein
wo ist der sprung ist aber okay
geschafft okay okay okay okay kohle okay
ich bin auch da wo du bist
einstiegspunkt jammern wir können
einschiffung setzen auf mich stört
einfach mal so nikon crafter steht hier
nur von online leiter spruch sagt blume
war das geschafft ist sich sicher das
ist unten das ist richtig krass dass ich
hier in dieser folge lassen dass ich mal
ganz kurz machen was ich in dieser folge
reiße ich bin einfach ein ganzen turm
runter gefallen wie weit oben sind wir
eigentlich wir sind schon im vorfeld
oben sehr sehr weit oben oder nach unten
gucken wir haben schon so viel geschafft
ich bin richtig stolz auf uns ich wusste
dass diesen leitspruch ich nochmal
parkplatz ich würde gerne einfach mal
wirklich ich mach das jetzt mehr spieler
vom ganzen turm runter damit ihr seht
wie weit wir schon sind und daher ganz
oben waren wir gerade und ich kann oben
schon an die decke gucken wo alte
schaffen ein sprung nicht du bist weiter
hat sich herrlich wo bist du denn ich
bin noch nicht beim einstiegspunkt ich
bin noch vor den betten beim
einstiegspunkt sind so richtig kag
leiter springer die rege mich voll auf
dann möchte ich im alter porsche ich
damals zu mir ich und wo ein niemals die
ersten vier sprünge gehen immer aber
danach ist der es so kacke auch verdammt
da gb aprilia bin ich ab flender mission
abfallberge ast ab sondern in denen ihr
dann hallo komme ich an dem ihr töten
sterben sehen was ich nein
jetzt habe ich mich so erschrocken dass
du gekommen bist einfach runter gegangen
du musst da um die ecken der schuss ist
behindert alter die sprünge die sind ja
oder hast du wenigstens nicht diesen
anfangs sprung machen muss dass den ich
gemacht habe
der einspruch eines sprung gesetzt und
möglich ja unmöglich
toyota nichts zu möglich kommen ohne
bulls müssen die folge die hat auch
gleich wieder ein ende habe ich will
einfach noch diese leiter springe ich am
liebsten schaffen dieser folge siehst du
mich gerade ab nee hab ich nicht ich bin
gerade gleich also ich bin gleich beim
einstiegspunkt ich würde aber sagen wir
beenden jetzt mal schafft er okay kommt
jetzt in einstiegspunkt geschafft dann
will ich sagen der nächsten folge bäume
kümmern wir uns darum dass wir womöglich
an diesem turm hier fertig kriegen
natürlich sagen es euch gefallen hat das
mag ich da guckt auch beim sommer vorbei
da kommt morgen die folge und dann sehen
wir uns mit der schau alter wenig war